make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and in
light of the fact that the flag smashers
are the main villains in falcon and the
winter soldier or at least the villains
that we're currently seeing i still say
that they're basically being used by
helmet zemo for his own ends no idea
what his ends are but probably to kill
superheroes to like wipe out all the
superheroes on earth that seems to be
the most basic premise given everything
that's happened but
i don't know if that's really true or
not i figured we'd do a video on the
flag smasher now here's the funny thing
contrary to what you may believe from
his name flag smasher or carl morgenthau
is not really just running around
smashing flags
although it would be funny if he was i
mean technically he was in his first
issue in his first appearance
we'll talk about here in a second he was
really smashing flags but that's not
really his thing right to like throw the
american flag on the ground and stomp on
it with vigor that's not really his
whole
that's not really his mo it'd be amazing
if it was but that's not really his mo
so so flag smasher first appeared in
captain america issued him at 312 back
in 1985 and he was created by mark
gruenwald but the funny thing about this
is that flag smasher had a kind of
unofficial three-part story
with captain america and the reason why
i say unofficial is back then in the 19
really the 60s 70s and 80s
you kind of had multi-part stories but
not in the same way that you do now
right like now if you go and you buy
really any particular comic it'll just
be
like part one part two part three part
four all the way up to part six right or
sometimes even part seven or eight even
as many as twelve if you're going for
like a maxi series and so the result of
this is that back then
it was all just kind of a loose series
of stories that were being told
now a lot of that just came off the
heels of chris claremont and his x-men
run that's why his run was so landmark
because it changed the way that comics
were written in marvel
that stanley and jack kirby did kind of
maintain that to a degree but by the
time that that
chris claremont came on you had roy
thomas who was taking notes from the
success of chris claremont you had
uh you had steve gerber who was doing
the same thing mark gruenwald
it was par for the course to like take
notes from just the monumental success
that claremont was getting with x-men
and then apply it to everything else and
so while the first appearance of flag
smasher came in issue 312.
the second part was in issues 321 and
322 followed by issues 348 and 349. so
it was kind of an unofficial three-part
series but the idea behind this is that
when he first shows up on the scene
really in the first issue we're given a
combination of both his actions as well
as his motives and that's one of the big
differences
is that back then the origin of a
character was usually given as some kind
of a flashback sequence in the comic
book or they would muse it to themselves
in this instance it was him just kind of
reflecting on why he was doing what he
was doing and just sort of musing to
himself but the idea
is that he was the son of a swiss banker
and that his father had basically left
the idea of finance behind
and instead championed the idea of world
peace the problem with this is that his
father was ultimately killed and so the
the belief of carl morgenthau was that
his father was basically too
light-handed
in his approach with regards to how
peace needed to come about now again
this is another example of marvel
looking at the success of the x-men and
then rolling it over
magneto is really the character that
this guy's modeled after right the
magneto was the guy who believed
in creating not really a peaceful
coexistence but basically eliminating
the threat of humanity against mutants
and would actually do things to
essentially eliminate humanity right
there was one
one point in the stories where he
implemented a worldwide emp a blanket
emp across the globe and basically took
down technology
all across the world that's the set of
events that almost led into fatal
attractions and then once he actually
did launch
asteroid m or really brought it back
that's what led into fatal attractions
itself when he stripped the adamantium
out of wolverine's body and things like
that
the important thing here is that the
motives behind flag smasher doing what
he's doing comes by way of the fact that
his actions and showing up at the u.n
and destroying the flags and then going
to the biggest flag manufacturer in the
united states and destroying that
draws the attention of captain america
and the results of this is that captain
america goes to publicly make a speech
in order to essentially draw flag
smasher out which works but when flag
smasher shows up here because nobody
really understood his motives the
captain america is actually thrown in a
tough spot and the reason why
is because the stance of flag smasher is
to say that he doesn't really believe in
the idea of nationalism
he doesn't really believe in the idea of
america or the soviet union or any of
those
instead he sees the idea of people
declaring themselves to be
part of a particular nationality right
so to be american or to be
south african or to be russian is
basically a way for them to say i am
something you are not
and a lot of that really is predicated
on how that particular country is doing
relative to others so there's a kind of
arrogance or or pomp and circumstance
that comes along with it but he sees
that as more of a problem for humanity
that humanity could achieve so much more
if it would simply cast aside the notion
of
borders and then operate as a singular
cohesive unit
the problem with this is that like so
many instances in the past even here in
the real world the message gets lost in
the conflict right let's go on a journey
for a second because we we always do
these real world comparisons to comic
books right let's go on a journey for a
second let me tell you guys a story
back in the early 1990s there was a man
by the name of larry gilbreath and larry
gilbreath was a ups
driver and larry gilbreath was dropping
a package off to a compound as he'd done
so many times before the difference is
that this
this package fell and broke open and
when it did he realized inside of it
were
automatic rifles and grenades and things
like that he reported his findings to
the local police who informed the bureau
of alcohol tobacco and firearms the atf
ended up getting a warrant after doing
their own investigation to search the
compound and when they got to this place
which was located in waco texas
that when they tried to execute the
warrant they were fired upon or
supposedly fired upon by the branch
davidians who were people inside this
compound and were led by a man named
david koresh who'd been preaching this
idea that the world was ending so they
had to like stockpile weapons and things
along those lines this ultimately led to
the fbi intervening
which went into a 51 some odd day
standoff where at the end of which the
fbi raided the compound
and the firefighting suit fire was set
in three different locations and when
the smoke cleared
70-something branches davidian men women
and children had died now in response
to the actions of the federal government
in waco and their actions at ruby ridge
the year before
a former member of the u.s military
named timothy mcveigh had decided that
the american government had become too
tyrannical and intended to use its own
foreign policy against itself by filling
a moving truck
full of zyklon b driving it to the
federal building in oklahoma city and
blowing it in half but if you ask
anybody about timothy mcveigh they'll
never tell you what he talked about in
his one page manifesto they'll say
he's the guy that blew the oklahoma city
building in half right the message gets
lost in the actions and that's the
problem that flag smasher is facing at
the moment right the issue that he has
is that with him going through and
committing what are deemed to more or
less be
terrorist acts that while his
motivations are sincere and captain
america even recognized that in
in their initial encounters like look i
get where you're coming from but the
important thing to understand here is
you're committing terrorist acts in the
name of a greater good
that this leads to people losing sight
of what it is that he's doing
ultimately he's called a communist and
everybody tears them down and they're
like get out of here commie and all that
kind of thing and they ultimately end up
deporting him from the united states
they boot him out of the country which
kind of sucks the thing about this was
that mark gruenwald wanted to create a
character that was not really your
villain of the week but he wasn't really
a guy who was showing up to rob banks
you know or or
implementing some scheme where it was a
distraction here but he was actually
doing something over there because that
had been done to death right that was
the cornerstone of stanley and jack
kirby storytelling and i don't really
say that to tear down stan lee or jack
kirby
i simply mean to say that by the time
you got into the mid-1980s because of
stories like the x-men because of what
dc was doing with regards to a lot of
their superheroes making them more
tangible more grounded more relatable
this basically meant that you had to
make villains similar to that right the
the evolution of magneto running all the
way up to uncanny x-men number 200 and
the start of his redemption arc is all
kind of testament to that right the idea
that that you know villains are or at
least can be far
more interesting than the heroes and so
creating a character
who is vying for this idea of unifying
the world in a way that had never been
done
but doing this through what are in
effect violent means
really provoked a lot of philosophical
thought and and even debate among fans
is is it one of these situations where
the ends justify the means right do you
look at that and just say hey you can't
make an omelet without breaking a few
eggs right i mean that's just kind of
the way it goes but regardless of how
you slice it the important thing is that
with mark greenwald kind of continuing
this trend that with captain america
issues 321 and 322
he introduced a group called ultimatum
now ultimatum stood for underground
liberated totally integrated
mobile army to unite mankind it's a
mouthful
i totally get it hits the reason why
they call themselves ultimatum but they
were by all standards of measurement a
group that followed the charter
of flagsmasher and we even were kind of
organized and inspired by him with
regards to the things that he had done
and the idea here at least the way it
intentionally went down
is that you basically had flag smasher
taking a plane hostage and then making a
broadcast to the world and essentially
saying
like captain america defeated me in our
first encounter that's true but it was
just blind luck right that's the only
reason why he did it i'm obviously the
superior fighter the two of us should
fight to the death and then if anybody
intervenes i'm gonna kill everybody here
right i don't want to hurt them but i
will if i have to now of course
this led to shield intervening and then
assisting captain america and then of
course you know carl morgenthau being
taken down again but the important thing
to get here is that this was sort of the
way his character functioned
in these early days the problem with
this was that you can't do the same gag
twice right you got to move on to the
next gag and so what you ended up
getting is that in
captain america issues 348 and 349 mark
grunwald
introduced the idea of red skull and
basically established this notion that
red skull had actually been the one that
was funding ultimatum and then basically
used that as a way to oust flagsmasher
from his own group the problem with this
is that by the time this had happened
steve rogers had basically been forced
out as captain america
by the commission on superhuman
activities and was replaced by john
walker by u.s
agent and so we ended up having flag
smasher approaching captain america with
his help to basically take down red
skull
because their idea was to initiate a
global emp that would render all
technology useless and actually cause
more harm for the world than good
then he was met by captain america he
didn't recognize and the two of them
actually went into blows and he got the
crap beat out of him but this of course
led to the two of them teaming up
and uh of course you know they ended up
defeating the red skull now with that
story ending
and mark greenwald's time on captain
america coming to a close right he wrote
from 1985 to 1995
the reality is that he was just ready to
move on to something else right the
notion of focusing almost explicitly and
kind of bringing back this villain
that really didn't resonate with captain
america fans all that often despite the
interesting nature of his stories and
despite the fact that he was shopped
around
basically meant that uh the flag smasher
had essentially vanished for nine years
right that his last appearance was in
ghost rider vol 3 issue number six
in 1990 we didn't see him again until
1999. and the reality behind this is
we've talked again about the the comic
book bus to the 90s and the notion that
by the time you got to 1995 1996
the comic books at least in marvel
comics were largely struggling just
because of the collector's market comic
book fans almost killing the industry
and so that basically meant that by the
time you got to the late 1990s marvel
was basically doing
everything they could to try to stay
afloat bringing back old characters
reworking old characters it was really
one of these things where it was just
throw it at the wall and see what sticks
and so with captain america annual 1999
joe casey wrote a story
where you have essentially had carl
morgenthau who came back and he was
basically captured by the roxanne ceo
calvin halderman and then turned into
almost a sort of incredible hulk s
character right not
exactly he was just giant grey and
mindless but the deep philosophical
discussions
of of mark gruenwald's flag smasher were
basically gone and instead he was just
used as a means to eliminate competition
or to take out people who were
investigating roxanne right because
roxanne is kind of this
super subversive terrible organization
that exists out there and has his hands
in some pretty shady stuff right so
think of like facebook before facebook
but the important thing is that that
ultimately once he was able to regain
his sanity and return back to normal
there wasn't a whole lot doing with him
right you got citizen v and the v
battalion the everlasting issues number
one through four
and then you got cable and deadpool
issue number 28 and that was really kind
of it right i mean
the way it all played out is that it
looked as though he was assassinated by
domino uh in the cable and deadpool run
but that was really just a way
for marvel to just kind of get rid of
his character right that he was kind of
seen as this holdover this unnecessary
being that was there and it was just
kind of done for the sake of doing it
right i mean by that point in time
nobody was really asking whatever
happened to flag smasher so it was as
though there was a motivation for
actually getting rid of his character he
was just kind of treated as a villain of
the weak at that point in time but at
the very least he was a character that
started out with these really
interesting philosophical viewpoints
on how to make the world a better place
but did so through some pretty terrible
means only for marvel to basically shove
him off to the cornfields when mark
greenwald was done writing captain
america and that was essentially it
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you